Así es un proceso de desminado
humanitario en Colombia uno de los
países que más víctimas ha registrado en
el mundo por Minas antipersonal este 4
de abril es el Día Internacional de
sensibilización contra su uso y Colombia
registró en el primer trimestre del año
un descenso de víctimas respecto al
mismo periodo de 2022 Aunque contó el
doble de muertes para comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja las
consecuencias van mucho más allá de los
datos en estos lugares las comunidades
sobre todo la población civil se ve
afectada porque no puede seguir
utilizando sus medios normales todos sus
bienes están afectados por la presencia
de estos artefactos exclusivos se
generan consecuencias como es limitación
para poder acceder a sus cultivos
poderse movilizar libremente en sus
territorios Acceder al agua casa pesca y
esto genera dificultades también para
acceder a los bienes y servicios
desde 1990 Colombia ha registrado más de
2.000 muertos por Minas antipersonal el
país llegó a tener 715 municipios
contaminados más de la mitad del total
de 1.122 tras el acuerdo de paz con las
Farc de 2016 el estado Ha logrado tener
cerca de 900 municipios libres de minas
una mejora que no bastó para estar libre
de Minas en 2021 fecha a la que se había
comprometido Colombia actualmente tiene
una prórroga hasta fines de 2025 pero el
objetivo se sigue viendo difícil los
grupos criminales que quedan en el
territorio colombiano siguen utilizando
Las Minas antipersonal